do you have those people that will tell
you the truth completely yeah i feel
like we definitely had a similar
experience growing up as child actors
where you're like on a set and i kind of
talked about it a little bit in the film
but like you like do a little thing and
they're like oh my god you're so
brilliant this is amazing and how
insecure that can make you because i
just remember being like oh i could do
the worst thing and people could you
know say that i did an amazing thing so
how will i know if i'm actually doing a
good job and i kind of like swung to the
other side of the pendulum where i just
thought everything that i did was bad
all the time okay whoa i'm having an aha
moment
this wasn't in my notes but
have we
accepted lesson relationships to
compensate for that possibly or i think
i
think maybe we like really like
criticism in that way because we didn't
hear a lot of it growing up and so i
don't know i definitely like gravitate
towards people who are like that in a
good way but maybe also in a bad way
that's an interesting yeah aha moment